[Music]
ann is in austin texas to start off this
hour hey ann how are you
i'm doing fine thank you cool so i see
on my screen that george challenged you
to do something what have we gotten
ourselves into here
well i had a credit card question and i
knew he was going to chew me out for
using them but
it was a question that
did he really did he really chew you out
i'm not capable no okay well he gave me
he gave me a good lecture
he wasn't gonna do that but it was but
it was like something that had bugged me
i don't remember even what he was now
but
he
was kind enough
to take some extra time with me and give
me a challenge to try to live
a month without them
and you did it and
well i did it because he asked me to i
didn't do it because i was convinced it
would work ah
but you're willing to
play along
okay so you went a month with no credit
card use i i take it you used a debit
card
no no use cash
and i ordered a debit card oh cool
so no plastic transactions for a month
yes
wow i'm impressed that's hardcore okay
so tell us about it what happened
well what happened was i i was a little
bit scared actually because i realized i
was gonna have to pay
for my credit cards that i'd used last
month
and take care of my expenses for this
month all at one time
and i go hmm this may be interesting and
you know what happened i got this little
feeling or something i don't know
whether i don't know what it was but i
just felt this wind between
under my wings and i went i can do this
i could do it so i decided i was gonna
do it and i was gonna do it right
okay so
yeah
so i took the i just i just
i just jumped into it right away and you
know what the strangest things happened
first of all
when i went to the grocery store
i didn't look left or right because i
know these are professional people that
are trying to distract me that's right
i'm not a professional in this area so i
need to
not be tempted and i also gave myself 10
minutes to be in the grocery store and
out
wow because you're using your own money
you've got it and you have to peel it
off like you're like you're bleeding or
something to give it to him or you can
just flash him apart when you hand it
over that cash it hurt
because you you left not only but it
surprised me it was even better than
that when i gave her the money she gave
me change
and you're like i forgot that you can
get change
you can change i had it in my hand i go
what do i do with this wow it was it was
so did you you spent less money you're
telling us that you spent less money
because you used cash if you don't put
anything in your budget buggy
you don't have much to pay for
what a concept
so you're saying when you use a credit
card it was like supermarket sweep you
were just filling up that card as fast
as you could and it felt like you were
getting it all for free
and i was doing a good job too
oh and you're hilarious well thank you
for humoring us and doing this
experiment so has it changed are you
going to go back to credit cards
[Laughter]
well my dog had to go to the vet this
month and i hadn't expected that that
bill and i i was i was a little bit
concerned but i paid for it out of the
change that was in my purse now
i'd gotten a focus that i hadn't had for
a long time so did you keep track and of
how much you saved by using cash using
your own money
i didn't have time i was putting money
in my purse so often i didn't have time
to keep the records but i can now oh
that's that's an awesome experiment so
it sounds like you've realized the power
of using your own money of using cash it
you make decisions differently that was
my whole point with you doing this
experiment
exactly i i understood it and i
appreciate the fact that i know you
can't give a challenge to everyone
not individually but i appreciate that
you did it for me you did exactly what i
needed exactly what i needed it i love
that anne thank you for the call that is
so cool i hope all of america takes the
challenge one month without credit cards
and see how it changes the way that you
spend well she actually went further
than you asked her to yeah you should
get a debit card and she hadn't even
gotten it yet so she does a pure cash
month no plastic at all which is the
best i mean that'll really make you feel
yeah i mean you want to get pissed off
about filling up your car
try walking all the way into the market
and laying down uncle benjamin franklin
a couple of times after you paid it off
now you're really getting bullied
that'll get you political right there
that'll get you angry calling your
senators after that angry
oh my goodness dave you've been dealing
with this for 30 years now this whole
argument of you spend more on a credit
card you make decisions differently when
you use other people's money and it
affects you negatively for your
financial future yeah the there's tons
of studies
that show that the pain centers of the
brain are activated when you spend cash
it literally
hurts
and when you spend with a card even a
debit card
it's just like
no brain activity no brain but no brain
activity right so uh but the you know no
that's all kidding aside there there's
you know total day and rachel brought us
something many many years ago and i
hadn't ever thought about it even though
i've been teaching by then this whole
idea for decades
when
when you're a kid
and you have a toy and your friend wants
a toy and you trade
you give him
your toy and
there's a there's a visual transaction i
and you won you ran it back in yours
right
a
purchase you're taking something
and you give them your money
and
they keep your money and you keep their
thing
just like a trade it's greenbacks for
stuff you see a trade when you are
purchasing something with plastic you
take their stuff
hand them your plastic and they hand it
back to you you leave with both things
see that seems that seems a little bit
childish when you think about it but you
know what there's no trade there's no
transaction here because i'm getting
both things
the thing i came for and the thing i
came in with i leave with the plastic
and the thing when i'd use money i don't
leave with the money yeah i just leave
with the thing and there's something
visually that happens inside of our
brains there that affects our emotions
affects our spirit and it lowers the
fact that we realize we just spent money
i think that's what's happening in
congress
oh my goodness yes and it's really hard
to go into debt when you don't have the
option to because your bank account said
empty
but it's easy when you've got the
lenders going we'll happily give you as
much money as you'd like card denied
when you have a debit card typically
means you don't have the money
it's a whole idea
this is the ramsey show